mme zhu zhu d'une bonne mesure ça permet
aux piétons de vos amis reculer milieu
des années 60 pour la première fois en
france une ville expérimente la
piétonnisation d'une de ses rues cette
rue c'est celle du gros horloge à rouen
pendant plusieurs jours la voiture il
est interdit de circuler plus facilement
ça dans la rue quoi n'a pas les voitures
qui nous gêne d'un côté ou de l'autre
donc vous êtes si pour certains
l'initiative est une réussite
d'autres au contraire n'hésite pas à
manifester leur mécontentement
les commerçants d'arrivée soloch au
peuple est content de ça parce que les
gens vont se garer à l'extérieur ils
m'ont qu'à leurs courses à l'extérieur
en france la piétonisation des
centres-villes prend de l'ampleur
d'autres villes tentent l'expérience
comme montpellier en 1970 avec
l'aménagement de deux rues moi je trouve
que c'est une bonne chose parce que les
voitures se met devant les magasins et
les gens ne peuvent pas rentrer dans les
magasins paris suivra la même année avec
la piétonnisation de 3 rue commerçant
pendant quatre jours c'est maurice
grimaud alors préfet de police de paris
qui lance les festivités le 19 décembre
[Musique]
justement votre mobile gêné par le
dessin depuis vous avez certains 15,8 ou
enrichissez à descendre l'avenue de la
gomera par exemple aujourd'hui dans
certaines villes des rues sont fermées
définitivement à la circulation et
d'autre quelques jours seulement dans
l'année par exemple avec l'opération
paris respire
des quartiers entiers de la capitale
sont rendues aux piétons
chaque premier dimanche du mois
[Musique]